three or four years ago i was on the
cnbc set with kevin o'leary that's right
the shark tank mr wonderful and kevin
said to me he forbid me from putting 50
percent of my net worth into bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies he said to me that it
was a scam it was all going to zero he
didn't see where the value was well i
gotta have to give kudos to mr kevin
o'leary because kevin not only got new
information went and did the work but he
eventually changed his mind and he
started to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies but just this morning
he went on cnbc squawk box and he
actually said that he has 20
of his portfolio in this industry now to
go from being a skeptic a critic all the
way to 20 of your investment portfolio
in the technology he's come a long way
and you got to tip your cap to somebody
who's willing to do the work and then
change his mind when he gets new
information but listen to him talk about
it this morning on television you're
like a uh
i don't know where you are in crypto you
were so negative for a while and just
definitive like you always are you may
know nothing but you're never in doubt
but you were so naive then you got
totally positive do you own bitcoin now
kevin what's your position in crypto
right now you do have you sold
it's 20 major parts of it you have a lot
of it
no no i look bitcoin is not a coin joe
it's simply software ethereum is
software if you want a bit you know hvar
software if you own microsoft if you own
google why don't you own bitcoin it's
all software it's productivity i mean
you own one bitcoin you own i mean do
you have a real position in it because
you're a wealthy guy
i have millions of dollars 20 of my
portfolio is now in cryptocurrencies and
blockchain that's a pretty big deal to
see shark tanks mr wonderful kevin
o'leary to come out and say yes i was
skeptical but now i'm going all in on
cryptocurrencies 20 of his portfolio
ends up being allocated to the space
that's pretty damn cool kudos to kevin
and i'm willing to bet we're going to
see many many more people following his
footsteps hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time